I don't take anything seriously and I find it hilarious
when people try to take what I do very seriously.
Aaron Reynolds is the creator of viral meme accounts like "Swear Trek" and "Effin' Birds"
which features serene woodcut style renderings of birds paired with profane maxims like
"Get some f*cking popcorn it's sh*tshow time,"
and "Someone should shove bees up your ass."
I don't have to yell at people or punch the wall,
I can make a bird very angry and put it on the internet
and then feel great about it.
In the lead up to the 2020 election just as Reynolds's Effin' Birds Instagram was exploding,
so was panic over so-called disinformation.
Under pressure from lawmakers, tech platforms crack down on content deemed unacceptable
by their algorithms and human moderators.
Reynolds is based in Canada, but 80 percent of his audience is American
and Instagram determined that the Effin' Birds account
had run afoul of the platform's rules
aimed at stopping foreign election interference.
I needed to turn on location services,
because they were concerned about accounts that had a large reach
and they wanted to make sure that people knew where those accounts were located.
And I was like, okay they're looking for election misinformation
and stuff like that,
and it's all images.
They can't tell a meme with election disinformation
from a picture of a bird and the word "Buttsauce."
Instagram initially added a location label
to all of Reynolds's posts indicating his account
was based in Canada and he proceeded as normal.
But then the company permanently removed "Effin' Birds" from its American explore page,
which is a recommended list of posts
Instagram shows to users based on their preferences and the posts popularity site wide.
Effin' Birds's reach on the platform plummeted.
On every post I would see that I would get somewhere between five and 10,000 views from the explore page.
And today I get zero on every post no matter how popular.
So did Instagram abuse its market power
by limiting Reynolds ability to reach new audiences?
I'm not owed their spotlight on their platform, that's their platform.
But I think the hard part of it is having had that pulled
because I'm a dirty foreigner, kinda sucks.
Reynolds distributes his content
across multiple popular platforms to mitigate his risk.
The reason that I'm on Instagram in the first place
is because I was stressed out about something like that happening on Twitter.
The algorithms are going to change.
And so if you put all your eggs in the basket of that algorithm, you're screwed.
Reynolds says that quirky outlets like his
could never have found an audience before social media,
which is what led to the publication of his new book available now in hardcover,
"Effin' Birds: A Field Guide To Identification."
Nobody wanted to put me on the radio or television
and nobody wanted to publish a book until it was popular on Twitter.
I'm not retreating to legacy media, I'm just finding another platform
and that platform is bookstores.
Bookstores have been great, there's this sort of magic of learning
that if you get in good with like an indie book chain,
they'll sell a ton of your books because they love you.
Like the number three seller behind Amazon and Barnes Noble
was a Boston area chain called Newbury Comics.
I was like, who are these guys and can I send them all cakes?
Reynolds says his experience with Instagram isn't an existential
threat to his meme business,
but he does worry about the potential danger of allowing the government
through explicit regulation or through its influence over tech companies
to constrain online speech.
If there's government involvement, we'll have the same kind of problems,
they'll just be different, or government-mandated versions of those problems.
I think it's funny that I'm lumped in with threats
to democracy and I post pictures of birds and swear words.